So I get to talk about our problem child and not have to not talk about the cure word or anything
like that. But I'm going to talk about the biology and the differences in extramedullary disease.
And when we talk about plasmacytomas in myeloma, we always, I see the good, the bad, and the ugly.
So the good is those who don't have plasmacytomas. Bad are those who have
perimedullary plasmacytomas. And the ugly cases and are hard, like hard to treat patients are
the extramedullary disease. And truly extramedullary disease with a plasmacytoma is not attached to the
bone, but it's only in soft tissue. And why is this our headache? When we look at data, even with
the newest agents that we have, like CAR-T and bispecific T-cell engagers, we see that CAR-T and
T-cell and bispecifics are suboptimal in terms of the responses that we're obtaining. At Mount
Sinai, we did a study with 134 patients with relapse disease who received CAR-T. And we saw
out of those 34%.
And 34 of those patients had extramedullary disease, 25 had perimedullary disease. And then
we looked at the response rate, we looked at the median progression-free survival and overall
survival. And we see that it's the extramedullary disease that really had the poor median PFS and
the poor overall survival. Those who had perimedullary disease or periskeletal disease
had a better PFS and overall survival and somewhat similar to those who did not have
any plasmasytomas. The other thing that we identified is that the tumor burden also
correlated with poorer outcomes. And the bigger the tumor burden, more than 50 centimeters
squared, that's when we saw the biggest impact in overall response rates and depth of response
with overall response rates of 57% versus those with small tumor burden of 81% and complete
response rates of 0%.
With heavy tumor burden and extramedullary disease. The other interesting thing is it's
not just the patients who have extramedullary disease at diagnosis or prior to starting therapy
that are going to have poorer outcomes. But the thing that we're seeing is that with these
new novel immunotherapies, both CAR-T and bispecifics, we're having a higher trend of
relapsing with extramedullary disease. So are we actually changing the biology of this
relapse?
Or are we just dealing with patients who have been heavily pretreated and who already were
destined to have all these mutations and we're just seeing the outcome of that progression?
When it comes to bispecifics, we see the same thing. Across the board, all of the bispecifics
are having suboptimal responses to patients who have true extramedullary disease. And
we see that these patients, they do better than conventional chemotherapy, but they still
have a suboptimal response. But what is leading to these suboptimal responses? And we see
that there's a genomic complexity in those patients that have extramedullary disease. And
the Mayo Clinic evaluated patients, and they did bone marrow aspirates, and they also did biopsies
of the extramedullary disease. They had six patients where they did these two samples
at the same time. The rest were at different time points. But we see that there is a clonal gene
mutation that is much higher in the extramedullary disease compared to the bone marrow aspiration. We
see a significant increase in the bone marrow aspiration. And we see that there is a significant
higher amount of tumor mutations compared to the bone marrow aspirate. And when we look at the
extramedullary disease, there really isn't any real significant difference in extramedullary
disease that is front line or after relapse or secondary. So it's as a class or as a group,
that extramedullary disease is behaving differently. And we should consider
this as a complete, by the way, as a completely different disease, but it is definitely a
different beast. And it's not a regular myeloma. We should have a classification for patients who
have true extramedullary disease. We also see that in order for myeloma cells to survive outside of
the bone marrow, they need to have independence of all the nutrients that are in the bone marrow
microenvironment. And we see that there are cell adhesion genes, alterations in these genes that
are overexpressed in extramedullary disease samples compared to bone marrow, where we see genes as
associated to cell adhesions like ROBO1, ROBO2, and FAT1 that are overexpressed and seen in up to 25%
of these extramedullary disease samples compared to less than 5% when we take a sample from the bone
marrow aspirate. And ROBO1 in particular also correlates with MMZ, which is translocation 414,
which is frequently associated with development of extramedullary disease in myeloma patients.
Now, there's been a multiple
studies that are identifying or studying particular alterations and gene expressions.
There's CD56 expression that is suggested to be also a contributing factor to survival outside
of the bone marrow, reduction of CXCR4 expression, and CD44 YALRA9 expression.
So, more to come. We need to understand these more. Is it a combination of these or is there
one particular that is actually causing these extramedullary disease survival? I would say that
this might be a combination because if we're seeing just 25% alteration in these samples,
that means that there's something else that's additive to make these cells survive outside
of the bone marrow. But we also have a dysfunctional immune microenvironment in
these extramedullary lesions. And when we sample these tumors, we see that there's reduced effector
tumor ratio, there's fewer CD4 T cells, there's more exhausted CD8 cells, and there's an enriched
CD16 negative NK cell population. In the areas where we see plasma cells, we see that there's
more exhausted TIM3 PD1 T cells in the areas of the plasmacytoma or extramedullary disease that
does not contain plasma cells, but it's more stroma. Then in those areas, we do see more
activated CD8 positive T cells and M1 macrophages. So, we're seeing different cells and components with
in the plasmacytoma, and it tends to be associated whether there's myeloma cells around it or not.
And we need to understand this better to be able to identify what is causing these changes in this
extramedullary disease, what's the microenvironment stimulation that's making these immune
compartments be very differently within the same extramedullary disease. And then just to summarize
and to keep with time, unlike my previous speakers, extramedullary disease should be considered
an aggressive and distinct variant of myeloma. We should have a special classification for
these population, and it has unique characteristics, marrow independence,
higher genomic complexity, pronounced clonal divergence, more dysfunctional immune
microenvironment. And as we learn and understand this better, then we can identify potential
targeted ways of treating this disease better. But at the same time, now that we're seeing,
for example, with redirect one, that we have a better response, what is causing this
additive effect of BCMA and GPRC5D that is helping overcome this so that we can start to tackle these
potential areas of niches that we can treat. And with that, I thank you for your attention.